[Music]
the film you play not just a
cyber-terrorist but maybe the greatest
computer genius of all time and I was
curious is this something that it all
relates to Javier Bardem in real life
not at all I mean I have a hard time
when I have to send an email so I cannot
really move these fingers that God gave
me yeah with some looseness in another
way the camera has to be behind the
computer for people to make people
believe that he was a computer so they
had they had to literally hide your
hands in order to make you look like a
computer genius yeah because you're just
[Laughter]
you're a really good actor because in
the movie oh my god he's the greatest
computer genius of all time and you just
keep hitting the tab over and over again
you obviously a lot of action in this
movie you have a lot of action scenes do
you I've heard Daniel Craig does his own
stunts what about you did you do all
your own stunts
yeah well I'm its Punisher I try the
tapas in the sense that I tried a little
bit glimpse of it in the sense that I
did yes like running from here to a
little taste it real taste
where daniel has did the whole meal
right oh right
Daniel will do everything and I'm a good
believer in stunt double work I mean I
will stay in the trailer and I mean let
me let the people get get get a job yeah
this is a great thing that is so kind of
you thinking of others luckily everybody
wins yeah you had a nap he risked his
life there's a lot your your your you're
not comfortable I've heard that you're
not comfortable with guns we did No
Country for Old Men you play one of the
greatest assassins of all time and then
I find out later on you weren't that
comfortable though the guns
no no III actually when I do those
scenes I have to put earplugs so he
don't get scared of the man the guy who
gives me the the weapons he will he
called me the Spanish ballerina that
would change movie so much if on screen
you could tell that he's like it that
makes you much less scary we have a clip
here from Skyfall I believe this is
where bond is chasing you through
through the tubes through the or through
the tunnels yes underneath London and
you are escaping I'm escaping I'm
playing a game with him he's like a
mouse cat thing yeah you and you you
you've got everything rigged in this
town through the computer let's take a
look at this amazing clip from Skyfall
[Music]
I won't miss next time silver look bad
not bad James for a physical brick what
thank you you got me now
here's your price latest thing from my
local toy store it's called radio if you
hope that wasn't for me
but that is
[Music]
training
you